Let's answer question e for consultation
popular April 21,
the one who talks about the hourly contract.
Thank you MW 42 for requesting it.
Ask for the next one and we will answer it.
You say,
do you agree with
amend the constitution of the
Republic and form the working code for the
fixed-term,
hourly employment contract
when it is held for the first time
between the same employer and employee,
without affecting rights
acquired from workers
according to nexus 4,
for me it is a rather difficult question
because I believe there are reasons for yes and no,
so let's see,
each splitting straight
more than 4 million people are counted.
as workers.
The biggest disadvantage is that if they want to have affiliation
have to do so
autonomously.
In the current Constitution
fixed-term work is not allowed,
that is,
you work from this date to this date,
or work by the hour,
that is to say that you as often as you come from work
you have to work so many hours
and it is now only legal to work indefinitely.
I see superpositive things for people who
either as an employer or employee
are entering the labor market for the first time,
because it really
this opens up the opportunity for people,
i.e.
students
that they only have a few hours to dedicate to him
to other activities,
can be hired by the hour,
i.e.
by contract You come
from 2:00 p.m.
to 6:00 a.m.
and as an employer he is superb.
That really
if you have a person in need
only in the morning,
for example,
you make him a contract
by the hour and there's really nothing like this waste.
that the remaining hours he would have to complete
by 8 o'clock,
you may have to restrict activities to him
to complete your working time.
Something positive
to formalize work by the hour or fixed term
is that it really
is statistically seen
which would increase the price per hour.
The Ministry of Labor
the price a person earns per hour
currently ranges from $1 fourteen to $60 and
and formalizing the work per hour would be considered 460
minimum wage dollars
divided for 40 working hours per week.
Payment per hour should be two
88 more than could be estimated at the moment.
Let's go for one of the no parts,
but first let's start by a lie.
terrible that it is enough to read a little bit
to know that it is not true.
Many people who support him do not say that in that sense.
many employers
would start putting their employees on an hourly basis,
making the payment of a great many
people down.
Yes,
it sounds terrible,
but the same law states that
the hourly contract is stipulated only
when is the first
contract between an employer and employee,
i.e.,
respecting people who are already working
under An indefinite contract law?
Now.
What I do not like very much about this law
is that you are really forcing companies.
Ah, let's say,
affiliate your employees.
And would you say maybe that if I have to force
more people to join them?
Dalíes,
maybe it won't benefit me that much.
And then it occurs to me that suddenly it might be that less
companies want to hire people by the hour.
Although it does encourage people to do so.
indefinite contracts,
I think it's a good thing too,
don't I?
In general I don't like it when they want to
oblige companies,
especially the private sector,
to do things by law.
For me
every company should manage as it wants and as it can.
Of course,
I do want to be an employer at some point,
I like it very much
that I just need someone to come and help me
about 4 hours a day,
then I contract him for hours.
I find it very beneficial
and then analyzing the pros and cons
on that question,
I would be voting,
yes,
clarifying something important.
And the fact is that also
all these laws,
all these reforms,
they make no sense
if they are not going to be regulated,
if they are not going to be controlled
and if no follow-up is to be applied
real than it is.
Because of course,
the rule is made,
made the trap.
Please leave me your comments.
Tell me what you think about this question,
Huh?
What are your views?
They can change my mind.
If they have a good plot
and please ask for the next question
and we will be analyzing it.
A big hug.
Follow me for more content.
Bye!